ah on n'est pas bien ici on est quand
même plutôt pas mal comment vous allez
tout va bien tout se passe bien pour
vous j'espère dit que le mois dès
maintenant bon commentaire aujourd'hui
c'est un truc très cool et je suis très
heureux parce que au pot pas si vous
connaissez au pot j'en ai beaucoup parlé
de pau au travers de différents
smartphones deux mondes connectés
d'écouteurs au poète un peu partout et
au pot c'est une marque écoute parce
qu'elles innovent énormément et
dernièrement vous ai parlé d'un
smartphone de pau qui s'agrandit juste
un prototype en fait c'est le au po x
2021 allez voir la vidéo si vous l'avez
pas vu en tout cas assez démentiel qui
ne va pas sortir en tout cas en l'état
tel qu'il est là il présentait sept en
proto est en tout cas super intéressant
et comment comment on peut utiliser les
écrans flexibles pour gagner de l'écran
non pas pliable mais flexible à son rôle
c'est plutôt l'idée assez bien et où
pour revient avec un tout nouveau
smartphone avec plein de nouveaux
smartphones et moi je vous en parlais
d'un aujourd'hui en particulier celui là
c'est ce smartphone et ce smartphone il
est très cool c'est le finepix 3 pro 5 g
[Musique]
et bonne nouvelle au pot vous aux vôtres
find x3 pro pour le gagner c'est très
simple vous a mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous cliquez dessus vous
participez et vous serez peut-être tirés
au sort pour des regagner votre find x3
pro alors il n'arrivera pas tout de
suite tout de suite un produit et à
t'annoncer laissez lui le temps mais dès
qu'il sera disponible
on vous l'enverra et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle dépêchez vous de
participer il n'y aura qu'un seul
produit
le lien est en bas dans la description
bonne chance à tous surtout pas voulu
faire plaisir avec un petit modèle
spécialement pour moi pour monsieur
records aujourd'hui justement on va
parler de ce smartphone parce qu'il est
extrêmement intéressant c'est le
smartphone de 2021 de au pot clairement
c'est le plus haut de gamme
on a donc cette gamme finepix la manière
na li fang x2 prot indique de neobe
compagnie le relais sur le finepix trois
pros arrivera plus tard mme allemand est
la gamme reno et compagnie donc pour
l'instant on ne parle que de ça on va
devenir de couper cette vidéo 2 partie
principale à toute première année ça va
être le nom boxing pour regarder à quoi
ressemble la découverte compagnie sied
ça et puis la deuxième partie qui va
peut-être la plus intéressante c'est
l'interview de david chauveau qui est le
chef de produit chez au pot qui va tout
vous dire tout vous détailler tout nous
expliquer je veux lui poser les
questions il va répondre à mes questions
je vais rebondir
il va re répondre on saura tout et je
pense que ça ça ça va envoyer du pâté on
va lire des mois ça comme c'est mignon
alors comment ça s'ouvre ça c'est le
premier portable à tintin
paf au cha cha cha pas mal à regarder
je n'ai même pas vu aurélien ça c'est
moi toute l'équipe au pot est ravie de
vous faire découvrir et on peut se
tutoyer l'équipe de pau vous fait
découvrir en avant première le tout
nouveau au profane mx3 pro avec lui
préparez-vous à révéler les couleurs du
monde qui vous entoure
à bientôt type de peau c'est vraiment le
packaging spécialement monsieur heureux
donc vous n'aurez pas c'est un bout
comme ça
chaque option d'où vient cette idée là
on a un bloc de charles toujours très
gros chez de peau on a ici de la super
vous qu on a les petits écouteurs avec
ça c'est une obligation en france voila
voila première chose que je vois que
j'aime bien tout de suite déjà c'est la
finesse je trouve très faim ce
smartphone et ça c'est un point qui est
vraiment vraiment très très très
positifs et l'autre point parce que je
les ai vus au prix brief déjà celui là
et bien c'est tout le travail qui est
fait au niveau du design
ça remonte ici au niveau de la caméra
vous avez vraiment un petit relief je
vois qu'au centre la junte seamicro qui
va être là pour la directivité lorsque
je n'irai enregistrés ont passé super g
quatre caméras
c'est mon petit branding au pot sur le
bas ok ça marche de la recharge ici en
usb servant classique tiroirs de cartes
sim qui est sûr de se moquer micro haut
parleur mono là je vais avoir mon
deuxième haut parleurs qui situe juste à
au dessus un micro pour la réduction de
bruit
ma caméra c'est le flic et planck est là
dites moi vous déjà ce que vous en
pensez que mon retrouver ce smartphone
en bas en commentaires ce qui pourrait
vous tentez oui non pas comment tout ça
[Musique]
on est avec les à david levitte chauveau
chef de produit chez oppose à bataville
ça sera bientôt très bien exposé heureux
d'être avec toi aujourd'hui pour voir
ces nouveaux produits
alors là on a plein de smartphones on a
le fun ii x3 pro dans les finepix 3d
relief and dicks trois là tu peux
m'expliquer un peu ce qu'il rate in ce
produit car il a des ailes en fête du
panier de la gagne pain x3 avec leproux
alors la gamme fans c'est vraiment la
gamme la plus exclusive de chez oppose
donc c'est lambin produiraient les
toutes dernières technologies et toutes
dernières innovations de la marque qui
est montré tout le savoir faire de la
marque donc que ça soit on a trois
produits qui sont déclinés dans cette
game quel que soit en déclinaison de la
gamme
on parlait d'un podcast effectivement
venir écouter les podcasts ans à venir
écouter bien dans la description je fais
de la pub merci j'ai zappé effectivement
quelle que soit la gamme on sait qu'on
sera sur des sur les bonnes performances
et les voilà quelque chose de pas
prendre ce soit au niveau de la photo au
niveau du processeur et c'est évidemment
sur cette nouvelle gamme on va pas lui
apporter des choses en plus puisque à
chaque fois qu'un fine sort une tour une
petite nouveauté quand même quelque
chose qui vient casser un petit peu le
web le marché a un côté qui disruptif le
fan ce trois procès le premier
smartphone au monde à prendre en charge
de bout en bout un milliard de couleurs
donc une qualité 18 hockey depuis la
capture photographique jusqu'à
l'affichage sur l'écran et donc c'est à
dire qu'il ya tout un tabac
d'optimisation alors un peu à la fois au
niveau hardware mais aussi au niveau
logiciel pour pouvoir prendre en charge
cette qualité la capture et l'affiché et
l'intérêt silva du coup je vais pouvoir
capturer des couleurs de marques plus de
nuances plus de subtilité et pour des
amoureux de l'image on va dire ça ça
leur permettra de travailler l'image
après coup la série à qui je m'adresse
vraiment savoureux l'image forte - aux
personnes qui va faire des photos et qui
veulent vraiment une qualité
exceptionnelle
oui mais pas seulement puisque après
évidemment même pourront venir pour le
grand public l'intérêt c'est d'avoir une
image de qualité et on sait que voilà on
s'habitue vite à la qualité en après
c'est plus quand on revient en arrière
qu'on se rend compte il est mon idée de
ce qu'on avait après effectivement c'est
subtil jeu pas sur créativement le
commun des mortels la différence sauf si
effectivement ali venir agrandir l'image
sur des
mon écran etc néanmoins on a aussi comme
des belles choses au niveau la
photographie sur le fal x3 pro on a un
double capteur principal c'est un
capteur qu'on nous a encore développé
avec sony qui est liée à mx à 166 et qui
permet la définition de 50 méga pixels
profondeur de couleurs de division 1
milliard de couleurs un autofocus très
performant qui va bien de supporter des
fonctions comme la vidéo focus tracking
aussi des fonctions assez assez
intéressante qui ont été ajoutés et sur
la lentille ou 30 ans on utilise aussi
une lentille de surface reform qui va
permettre de corriger au niveau physique
la distorsion forces commencent à votre
iphone alors tifrit fois en fait c'est
l'anti qui sont assez coûteuse à
produire alors qu'elles sont gravés
point par point avec au cristal et donc
ça permet en fait c'est de serrer une
forme qui est pas régulière mais c'est
justement à permettre de corriger la
distorsion et contrôler parfaitement la
lumière au niveau de l'optique en fait
c'est vrai qu'au niveau l'optique alors
sa part ça corrige tout mais ça permet
de limiter grandement les algorithmes de
compensation et donc d'altérer la
qualité l'image et le rendu c'est qu'on
n'a pas distorsion notamment sur les
bords de l'image et en un grand-angle
natifs qui est de 110 degrés donc
c'était plutôt pas mal
ok ça on n'en pas au fret est alors
d'ici quelques jours sur youtube donc
abonnez-vous on regardera tous les tests
photos vidéos on verra tout donc comme
ça on fera un tenu informé c'est très
bien ça voilà donc en tout cas vous
savez que sur le grand temps comme sur
le terrain en tant que vous à une
qualité qui sera pas qui sera pas
sacrifié sur l'ultra longtemps que c'est
exactement la même qualité et les mêmes
fonctionnalités
les mêmes capacités tout ça en un
milliard de couleurs et ensuite on a
également un tel objectif
un nom qui permet de faire un zoom
optique x 2 il veut une fois 5 et
numérique jusqu'à fois vingt et une
dernières antique est aussi une petite
nouveauté qu'on retrouve nulle part
ailleurs qui est la lentille microscope
alors moi je les ai vus lors des
présentations presse il ya un effet wow
je suis un peu moins sûr au niveau du
visage mais bon on a parlé dans le
podcast donc levé jeter une oreille
comme ça vous serez tous alors au niveau
de la lentille microscope on compte
offrant ainsi au fait que quand je
l'actif une petite lumière qui la sas à
lui autour de la lentille c'est à dire l
une est bloqué c'est pour éclairer les
éclaire la partie puisque contrairement
aux maquereaux on va ta 3,4 centimes est
ici je devrais venir coller la lentille
et ça c'est la fille de tournezy dans
cette loi c'est hyper impressionnant
à quelle distance à tulle pose en fait
sur le live je le faisais
l'air très légèrement l'arrière du
téléphone pour faire les mines et enfin
la mise au point en fait c'est assez
incroyable que je peux même venir
effectivement zoom est aussi encore
davantage tu viens zoom numérique après
dans le foot à la cua c'est absolument
incroyable
alors moi je veux ça rigolo c'est la
question de l'usagé mais ça il faut de
plus une as tu n'aurais dans le podcast
passe comme ça vous serez tous messi
très très bon en fait c'est très bon
vous êtes aujourd'hui le seul à faire ça
ce marché oui en tout cas sur ce matin
oui il ya des appareils-photos
spécialisés mais du coup de solutions on
n'achète que pour sa part soit plus
haute la macro ou la macro tu viens tu
lis a filmé ce que ce que tu voire nuls
à tarif quand même tendu testé sur du
microscope optique en fait ouais faisons
est par exemple
voilà c'est des exemples de photos que
j'ai fait moins ça c'est une photo de
fleurs fanées par exemple on retravaille
qu'un filtre ça me tue le reconnaissait
ouais ok là j'ai ajouté un filtre sur
celle ci ça c'était aussi une fleur ça
c'était alors ça c'était juste comme ça
sans s'approcher de quoi que ce soit
mais je trouve les faits c'est joli ça
c'est une brique
ça c'était papier avec deux langues ça
c'est un voilage de rideau les rideaux
transparents ouf on peut vraiment voir
un tout larchitecture ça c'est une balle
de yoga si c'est intéressant devant
l'air
la texture c'est qu'il ya l'effet waouh
pas que c'était le truc je trouve
intéressant là dedans c'est
qu'effectivement tu retrouves ton
environnement
je pense que certains que je refais mon
fils je dis tiens elliot on va prendre
le fun ii x3 pros et on va aller
s'amuser mais le problème c'est qu'après
la vouloir prendre va vouloir aller au
jardin et j'ai peur mes enfants je pense
qu'ils veulent
j'ai donc tout est parti au niveau de la
photo au niveau de la thur la charge
superbook chargeur rapide
oui alors la petite nouveauté c'est
qu'on a également ajouté pour la
première fois en france la charge sans
fil également sur ce produit donc
chargeant pitch âge sans fil
propriétaire au pot 30 watts donc qui
permet de récupérer 100% 80 minutes et
avec la charge hier c'est 100% en 35
minutes
le chargeur est fourni dans la boîte je
précise merci donc là on a plus d'eau
avec un effectif
non justement avoir cette charge là
effectivement et aussi parce qu'on a
fait le choix d'avoir un design
monocoque a lancé du verbe forget à
chaud avec un design vraiment très
particulier fins traits distinctifs dans
la mesure où effectivement le dos du
téléphone vient épouser le module photo
avec des bords incurvés un donc c'est
tout ça s'est forgée d'une seule pièce
ça c'est intéressant ça c'est vraiment
différent
on le retrouve nulle part du coup ça
permet aussi d'avoir aucun smartphone
qui on a vraiment travaillé sur l'
architecture des composants pour un
smartphone qui est fin et léger en main
ça c'est quand même aussi intéressant
parce que sur l'ultra en vigueur
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en général les téléphones sont assez
basses fins costaud on va dire plus de
220 grammes là on est à 193 g en main il
n'est pas trop lourd il est pas il n'est
pas trop imposant donc la photo le
design qui va peu différent la légèreté
on a un écran avec une super qualité
tout en fait j'espère toujours 120 hertz
oui adaptatif ça c'est la petite
nouveauté on voudrait permet aussi
d'avoir une amélioration de l'autonomie
par rapport aux familles de pro à bout
assez de génération au niveau de l'écran
aussi on à la partie comme un éternel
puce de traitement d'image qui permet
aussi d'avoir une amélioration de la
résolution sur par exemple des vieux
contenus qui sont en moins de 720 p on
peut les trouver retirant 1089 scaling
vous la vie à 120 jeunes sur le phénix
d'eau pour nom s'était pas tout à fait
la même
en plus des lots de votre épaule il y
avait une puce mais qui faisait de la
cité pour la flûte et l'image on
pourrait rajouter des c'est
l'amélioration du free moins nettement
qu'aux lieux tout en images par seconde
c'était 60 images par secondes
exactement ça dépend sur le pro donc on
a aussi bas en termes de performances un
quelque chose de très très bien ce qui
se fait de mieux sur android en 2021
snoberaient bonus à 88 188 12 giga de
ram 256 go de stockage 12 igad rabal
payer des arts 5
c'est ça c'est lui ai fait trois par les
trois points ok ça marche qu'on la
combativité ici me suis-je pas précisé
ok donc c'est du double sim compatible
ici mais donc un très beau produit qui
est commercialisé donc à 1149 euros
c'était à peu près le prix derrière ce
phonique de proust et en était à 1199 au
sol sur le dock et donc on a même fait
une toute petite baisse de prix
appliquée par rapport au dernier et
ensuite on passe aux néo donc il ya un
produit aussi hyper intéressant qui lui
est commercialisé à 799 euros
on va retrouver le même capteur
principal que sur le
x3 pro donc un capteur co développé que
sony on a également le même tes
objectifs on apparente un ultra
l'entente qui va être différent et un
capteur micro au niveau du design
on a quelque chose d'aussi de avec une
finition exclusive vopos ce qu'on
appelle au pogo qui est donc anti traces
de doigts résistante aux rayures et
espèce de matières en fait sur le même
c'est légèrement très très faim comme du
sable très texture ise en tête ok super
très agréable au toucher une petite
nuance quand même par rapport aux entre
la version argent galactique et le noir
c'est que sur la version argent galactic
la petite arrête là la petite bande son
sur le dessus elle est phosphorescente
pour retrouver son téléphone dans le
noir ça seventh voilà que le petit
détail qui tue donc plutôt sympa ça
c'est mort très bon niveau de l'écran on
a un toujours sur le led avec un écran
un rafraîchissement de 90 hertz hockey
très bel écran certifié hdr dispute si j
netflix 1er août par exemple je ne suis
pas de la plupart inscrits seront
toujours la même charge rapide que sur
leproux c'est comme ça c'est un point
qui commande tout légal 65 watts d'un
côté de l'autre comme super g pour le
light on a donc un design qui est aussi
alors lui textures et on a deux versions
qui sont dans texture is et textures is
est ok avec la version hop au boulot
alors faire une petite différence sur le
sur le argent galactique on est sur du
verre on a surtout vu polymères et on a
aussi une version noir brillant plus
classique fois aux et sur du verre et de
l'autre côté sur un côté plastique je
savoir apollinaire cette texture la fin
se ses effets de couleurs on peut le
faire qu'avec quelques averses qui a
plusieurs couches à l'intérieur ça ne
peut plus cher à faire ça ou pas je
pense que ça coûte plus cher mais donc
ça veut dire que soit le modèle en vrai
aller coûte plus cher on diminue les
barrages face aux autres d'augmenter
l'offre parce que ces mêmes prix de
vente je pense qu'on diminue les mecs
qui viennent charger sur les marques
ok mais c'est intéressant qu'est ce
qu'il raconte le lay par rapport aux
autres alors le light il est pour moi
c'est 1,5 million de gains mais qui a
presque tout du haut de gamme
puisqu'on va conserver un écran oled 90
hier sont très belles filles des écrans
ouais on va conserver la charge du très
rapides également par contre
effectivement on va avoir un petit peu
moins de mémoire que sur le neo sur le
propos ici on va durer 8 gigas de ram
puces en 28 j ai le stockage on essaie
de pays d'un 4 x la wii sur le neo est
sûre light sur neo et sur la toile ok
moi je suis très très bien ok et
et au niveau de l'appareil photo aussi
un petit changement sera pas plus tout à
fait les mêmes capteurs à part pour le
capteur selphy qu'il commun toute la
gamme et qu'un capteur sony également 30
2 mégapixels et à l'arrière c64 +8 pour
lui présente angles et un capteur d'un
croc un capteur pour le portrait ok
super au niveau du nez on voit pas digne
on a le stade rigaud en 1865 wiki et le
processeur le plus haut de gamme de
l'année dernière de chez qualcomm
c'est un plus haut de gamme du marché
est de toute façon et sur le live pour
la coiffe on est sur du 7 165 g 765 donc
on avait réussi dernière et qui marche
très bien et qu'elle aurait d'accord ok
donc on est sur des produits soient les
trois des produits grand public
on le voit assez quand même sur la photo
et surtout trop plus plus plus bien
évidemment expérience photo extérieur
gaming experience
bon visionnage s'il ya des compagnies de
tous les jours à pilas le faire aux
charges parce qu'il ya besoin
particulier à la gamme finepix jeu on va
effectivement c'est plus haut de gamme
aujourd'hui sur pau mais ce cas une aden
particulière il ya des concurrents qui
sur leur haut de gamme bien plus
vraiment sur la photo sur la vidéo est
ce que c'est là dessus que vous devrez
vous recherchez les gens ne serait ce
qu'au travail marketing est ce que vous
dites que vous le faites là dessus en
outre la gamme fans c'est plutôt
l'aspect innovation performance donc mes
performances globales j'entends sur les
performances processeurs fin de
l'interface mais aussi sur la photo
c'est un c'est un peu un tout puisque
effectivement sur le pont à quelqu'un
pas mal d'innovations au niveau de la
photo également que au niveau de la
recharge etc
la gamme reno pour nous et peut-être
plus la gamme justement qu'on va
orienter leurs photos vidéos et un peu
tendance aussi au niveau dizaines ouais
mais là en général à galfingue celle qui
va introduire des nouvelles innovations
qu'on va ensuite retrouvée sur la lame
reno et flippe un peu plus tard
potentiellement sur la gamme a également
fait cas non cadres écoutez j'ai hâte de
tester gelé depuis quelques jours les
ouvrières donc je suis super heureux et
très curieux je trouve ça intéressant
vraiment j'aime beaucoup ce côté très
léger j'aime beaucoup ce design je
trouve bien bossé et j'ai hâte de tester
de voir cet écran de voir la photo de
voir tout ça ça fait courir sur logiciel
de la coloriste 11 dessus mais
effectivement que le rsa apporte un
certain lot
d'amélioration au niveau
personnalisation on peut voir que déjà
dans l'est dans le menu dans les
paramètres on a créé un élu qui
s'appelle vraiment personnalisation ça
c'est nouveau ça fait vraiment partie de
l'adn de colorer c'est qu'on peut
vraiment grands noms personnaliser son
sang sont l'interface est donc par
exemple on va retrouver donc ici les
fonds d'écran ça c'est classique le
style des icônes donc ici je vais
vraiment pouvoir complètement changé de
style de musique aux jeux peut aussi
changer les agrandir s'agrandir même la
taille du logo à l'intérieur je peux
aussi désormais ça c'est nouveau
supprimés par d'amples texte ou
l'agrandir je peux aussi désormais
choisir la disposition de l'écran si je
veux plus ou moins de lignes sur l'écran
donc voilà une réaction qui est
peut-être qui est peut-être avant -
l'application sur l'écran la couleur des
menus enfin pour les icônes etc
tu vas au niveau de la personnalisation
fait il vraiment l'idée de la couleur
rose ça va vraiment très loin bon ça
c'est le ça ça existe déjà c'est
l'éclairage des bords pour quand on a
des notifications et petite nouveauté 6e
très sympa c'est la l'horloge always-on
on peut vraiment fait dessiner sa propre
horloge
c'est là où tu vas uta intéressante
autour de rafraîchissements avoir dû lui
dire tu sais sur le web notamment
effectivement parce que du coup ça va
éviter de trop consommer et donc ici
dans ce dans cette heure-là jeu pouvant
choisir le type de motif que je veux
ensuite la couleur commencé à dessiner
des petites choses comme ça tu te
décides entre le toit du recto way va
reprendre sur les côtés voilà chers mais
je peux vraiment fait m'amuser à faire
ma propre horloge avait un petit côté
créatif très sympa tac appliqué et donc
ensuite rien d'un s'activer sur le sur
l'écran est un avenir se dessiner je te
remercie beaucoup de villes super
intéressant plein de nouveautés chez au
port le test d'ici quelques jours donc
je vais pas vous abonner si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas
et puis bien évidemment à acheter une
oreille war 2 oreilles soit podcast
parce qu'on parle de la mare on parle
également avec denis morel qui est chef
de aux france et on parle de la marque
de l'évolution on parle de ces produits
ont dit plus enfin c'est super merci la
ville merci à toi merci à vous prenez
soin de vous et puis surtout dites moi
ce que vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire vous voilà parce que
j'avais à vous dire aujourd'hui sur ce
nouveau smartphone de au pôle phoenix 3
produit pas ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce que vous le
trouver intéressant est ce que vous
pourriez vous aussi tenter ce que vous
connaissiez au pot parce que des gens
qui ne connaissent pas encore on peut
aujourd'hui c'est une marque qui se
développe c'est une marque qui développe
énormément qu'on voit un peu partout et
notamment sur un bouton vingtaine isc et
ronan guerre
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire quand on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler texte tu
dois parler bien sûr de au pot parce que
oui parce que oui il ya quelque chose à
dire des bisous des coeurs et beaucoup
d'amour chaos